talk to me about this this collecting
because or you said you collect vinyl
which I never understand but okay you
collect vinyl but you also everyone
knows you worked in a um video store
when you were young but when the video
store went out of business you set up in
your house yeah this incredible it's
it's it's a video story you bought all
of the videos that they had and you set
it up like a video store in your home
what it I maybe I understand a little
bit the fascination with the the final
mhm but why why videotape when you could
have uh all these films on you know
digital okay so it went out of business
I think in uh the store went out of
business in I don't I can't remember if
it was 97 or 98 something like maybe 97
or something uh um so when I bought all
the video Cass sets then wasn't some
retro thing I was doing that's what we
watched we watched video cassettes it
was the techn techology of the day it
was the technology of the day but also I
had invested so much in that collection
I wasn't going to watch it be uh uh sold
to Blockbuster for you know three cents
on the dollar uh I I invested my 20s
into that collection do you think that's
what makes you a great director in the
fact that you have I I imagine a great
memory for all of these films that you
watched you watched them over and over
again and now they're ingrained in your
head and maybe to become a Master
filmmaker you need to draw on what other
directors did and you need to draw on
film references it's not so much I'm
taking something but it's
just the fact that so much of my early
life I was just immersed in film yeah I
was just IM immersed in it you know not
too dissimilar from somebody who is a
good football player and loves football
is like immersed in the game and is
immersed in the history of the game yeah
I guess I compare it to painting the way
I learned to paint was i' look at Master
paintings and say how did this guy paint
a tree right exactly I don't know how to
paint the tree I don't know how to make
a tree come to life on a piece of paper
but here's a guy who did right exactly
yeah and you study that and then by and
then all of a sudden oh I oh these four
strokes gives me a tree now what I want
to do with that tree after those four
strokes is up to
me